hello and welcome to this video cortex
for weight I had a game against him with
a net bank all-star see 5 B 5 l equals 4
Knight f3 giveth the more in control
yep understand okay the water slightly
inaccurate but people rarely use this
and here also dozen 23 is a bit better
[Music]
when this is perfectly okay of course he
goes into the mainline but he didn't try
to exploit my son what substandard you
water now it feels it feels like a
Hector's against a meanie fits a bit - a
loo kind of I cannot go up the age added
blunder c5 pawn not so happy in at this
move okay
where is he going with this not question
to h6 an interesting question is if this
is it is an interesting question if I
can play f5 or not here probably not
it looks to weakening to me maybe I
could have played d5 actually and it
could play p5 maybe okay so he played
this in a very ambitious way the
question is is it a good way I mean I
have this with a central counterplay
yeah I know he's five but I'm not sure
how bad this is I have this moment for
d3 so maybe it may be why does a lot
better but I'm not entirely sure about
it okay I'm pushing it back and now what
to do
and maybe just the Queen Queen over to
deform the bishop g5 was interesting
okay okay I wonder if I should play like
f5 here yeah simply block before and
everything he cannot take I think that
that gives me too much like it takes
only one D - that's too much now I have
some interesting ideas maybe actually
what what the heck that works I would be
amazing
okay now I don't I can't have to take
anyway how can that work Queen D one
more interesting but but I can probably
just run with the king okay okay place
reason is okay so let's let's check this
it is so it's a very complicated a very
complicated position now or it's hard to
hard to evaluate yeah this is some the
engine gives roughly equal here it's
it's not easy to play this yeah now I
push the five that is completely
completely unclear the computers
evaluation is roughly equal
in this position but he had wants to
play Bishop g5 head looks and looks far
more natural than the game continuation
the main line is just a bunch of weights
actually like this this okay check
reacting to a 1 C 1 and so on
yeah I'm probably active enough this is
now it's not not all not that easy to
play for white Jenny between before
those interesting but I like this is a
good controlling move white cannot take
and I'm taking away f4 to f5 94 and so
on so they're taking you cannot change
this and d2 should win a pawn is too
strong ok yeah that doesn't work it just
doesn't work this is too much okay yeah
thanks for watching guys
[Music]